After you unzip the downloaded file, you can open it up and
see the file structure within it.
Notice how there are two versions of everything with the same name.
We have bootstrap-theme.css and
bootstrap-theme.min.css and the same goes for JavaScript.
When a user opens your Web page or rather, when their browsers open the Web
page, they'll have to download all of the style and
JavaScript files that you've included in it.
Sometimes these files can be quite large.
So to help avoid that problem, we use minified files.
Minified CSS and
JavaScript files take up less space and can be downloaded faster.
On the left side,
I've got the unminified, the normal version of bootstrap.css file open.
Notice how it looks pretty normal, but on the right,
I've got the minified version of the same file.
These two files are the same, but all of the white space has been taken out of
the minified version, while on the unminified version, it is still readable.
You should always include the minified version of your files on your site so
they can be downloaded faster.
But when you're editing, you should definitely use the unminified version.
Otherwise, you'll drive yourself crazy trying to figure out what's going on.